on sait la téléréalité est un format
souvent basées sur les clashs et autres
embrouilles et les hanches format
précurseur de ce type d'émission ne fait
pas exception
sauf que voilà ces clashs ne serait pas
toujours initiée par les protagonistes
de ces émissions mais serait parfois
orchestrée par la production elle-même
un encouragement au harcèlement que des
nôtres aujourd'hui plusieurs candidats
de l'émission les anges
selon angel rawal céline et natanya qui
se sont exprimées lors d'un live sur la
plateforme instagram tu veux pas forcer
la victoire je partirai avec personne et
si ben arfa casting de talent la
production d'émissions forêt en sorte de
pousser certains candidats à s'acharner
sur d'autres pour créer des séquences et
faire le buzz
angel victimes de ces attaques a demandé
à ne plus apparaître dans l'émission
pour le moment sans succès de son côté
as well prétend que la production de
l'émission aurait tenté de l'intimider
parce qu'elle a souhaité ne plus
participer au programme un cri d alarme
qui a été entendu par de nombreux
internautes qui ont décidé de lancer le
hashtag boycottent les anges sur twitter
un mot clé qui s'est retrouvée en
première place des sujets les plus
commentés en ligne alors harcèlement
menaces intimidations comprenez vous les
appels au boycott de l'émission les
anges
angèle natanya iraniens sont avec nous
ce soir pour tout vous dire des
coulisses de cette émission
et c'est vrai que vous étiez très
attendu merci à vous trois d'être là on
gèle natanya et rania merci d'être là à
toutes les trois et c'est vrai que quand
on écoute vos histoires on se dit c'est
complètement fou harcèlement menaces
intimidations c'est vrai qu'à des on
vous a entendu dire des trucs fous
alors on va voir un premier extrait
angèle vous avez expliqué au cours d'un
live un stade que les filles du
programme étaient vus comme des bouts de
viande par la production et les mecs du
programme c'est vrai que ça fait
énormément parler sur la glace targa
mais choqué c'est nova ce qu'elle nous
avait dit quand elle est venue qu'on
n'oublie fait avant qu'on vend dans
l'aventuré elle la vit avec eux les fils
et anzhi mot pour mot sur l'exode ma
mère c'est vrai elle nous dit bob alexis
franchement les mecs ils n'en peuvent
plus ils sont à l'hôtel ils vont
exploser des cadeaux de vous prendre une
giclette stage avant qu'on rentre dans
la séquence bac première séquence n'aura
leur revient et elle nous dit elle nous
dit m elle nous dit ouais franchement
hadi de la voiture en mode fait par la
marchandise savoir quand elles sont
fraîches ça genre les morceaux de chair
tu vois alors ça c'est le premier
extrait qui a fait énormément parler
angèle c'est en fait comment vous êtes
arrivé vous dans les anges de la télé
réalité
alors ce sont eux qui m'ont contacté moi
à la base je travaillais avec une autre
production sinon approchez-vous travail
effectué sur quels produits travaillés
avec by dj d'accord qui est une très
belle boîte oui une production vous avez
changent de mal fait de changer de
crèmerie bras venir chez paddy du oui on
verra plus tard
voyons donc oui et vous ont débauché
vous posiez quoi faisait quoi sheibani
tuer la même chose que dans les anges
étaient candidats de télé-réalité
d'accord pour quelle émission est les
marseillais très bien oui qui cartonne
en plus utile le cross d'accord est
exactement donc là et la production des
marseillais et la production des anges
rien à voir mais c'est bien ça le
problème justement c'est ce que on
expliquer avec les ici c'est que il ya
le jeu de la télé réalité donc bien sûr
il ya des clashs il ya des histoires
donc faut savoir une chose c'est que une
télé réalité je suis désolé de casser le
mythe mais il ya un scénario il ya une
littoral tram et une trame assurent
souvent ça on vous envoie des travaux
vous dit voilà c'est une mise en
situation donc on va prendre des
personnages pour leur caractère pour
leur personnalité et ils vont par
exemple les confronter à un tel qu'il
peut pas blairer intel ils vont les
mettre ensemble et ça va créer un clash
donc je dis quoi par exemple j'ai le
poulet vous voulez vous faites chier
quoi c'était quoi votre personnage vous
dites là vous parlez quel programme
non mais voilà sur les anges où vous a
dit quoi c'est à dire on vous a dit tu
vas jouer tu vas quelques indications
vous donnez là les indications en hausse
était en fait c'était un petit peu tu
vas voir ça va être génial ça pour te
montrer peut-être que tu es
enfin voila tu vas on va pouvoir voir
tout sur moi pour te voir tel que tu es
et on vous dit pas clairement
explicitement évidemment on dit on va
voir ce rôle là on m'a dit tu vas avoir
le rôle de la justin semblait jamais dit
mais mais bien sûr on me fait comprendre
qu'il faut que je me rapproche de ces
garçons et ces accords mais tout ça
normalement c'est censé être joué c'est
ce que nous on disait c'est à dire que
par exemple dans les marseillais oui il
ya aussi des scènes de clash
bien sûr mais la différence c'est que
lorsque les caméras s'éteignent
tout tout tout reprend son chemin enfin
je vais dire les enjeux ça continue
ouais ils ont ému je le suis c'est bien
de faire des révélations incroyables
dans quelques instants on passe tout de
suite à la dernière partie d'ailleurs
les midis et c'est vrai que on dit que
vous avez été victime d'un acharnement
au sein des anges
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour les
trois qui veut des mains angèle ça veut
dire quoi un acharnement
oui alors en fait ce sont tout
simplement 15 personnes qui vont se
mettre sur une seule candidate et qui
vont la pousser
psychologiquement à bout et ça c'est
vraiment à travers à travers des
humiliations des insultes moi dans mon
cas on m'a balancé du ont aspergé le
visage de produits ménagers
on m'a insulté de clément le terme de
[ __ ] [ __ ] et ses fans voilà on m'a
menacé de me frapper on l'a voulu me
frapper
la production m'a enfermée à clef dans
une chambre doit oui c'était à moi alors
parce que j'ai été agressé en fait là le
problème
ouais c'est que j'ai été j'ai été
agressé par deux candidats physiquement
ce ne sont pas ces candidats qui ont été
sanctionnés non c'est moi qui l'a été
c'est moi qui a été mise à part alors
que j'ai subi une agression et on m'a
enfermée dans une pièce c'est quoi la
laissant passer les ondes aux
téléspectateurs dont vous êtes dans une
émission vous subissez la question
qu'est ce qui s'est passé l'agression en
question oui alors à chaque fois sa part
toujours de deux fins de raisons qui
n'ont aucun sens c'est des trucs
complètement débile cdc dfs les
prétextes pour s'acharner sur nous c'est
n'importe quoi c'est l'étonnement
il donne ce cet ordre de vous acharner
sur une personne ces quads anti ses
marines et dans le scénario
subtilement c'est à dire que c'est ces
personnes là sont encouragés par la
production
donc en fait par exemple si il y à un
candidat qui je tiens à rappeler une
chose qui est primordial c'est que nous
sommes employés
la grosse équipe aucune autre employeur
donc il y a les lois du travail qui
doivent être respectées et par exemple
vous sert il prend en exemple si vous
surprenez un chroniqueur en train de
consommer la drogue sur son lieu de
travail vous sanctionner ces je
l'encouragé il sort il sort directement
si vous surprenez une candidate
une chroniqueuse en train de tirer les
cheveux du nos chroniqueurs vous l'a
sanctionné sinon c'est pas bien c'est
bien ça veut dire que ces essais voilà
même ma femme m'a fourni coeur voilà qui
je vais vous dire je sais ce que voulait
dire c'est que la production privilégie
le casting existeront peut pas se passer
de ces personnes et qu'il ya des gens
qui font ce qu'ils veulent
dans cette production c'est ce que
voulait dire exactement et c'est plus au
nord c'est à dire qu'en fait lorsque ces
candidats donc commettre des actes
illégaux et soient encouragés mais c'est
vachement bien ce que tu fais c'est
génial continues tu es trop fort je vais
vous donner un exemple il ya il ya une
année une candidate qui un candidat a
balancé deux sauts de javel au visage
non oui et il a il était sur le point
lui balancer un sceau du rin pour faire
plaisir à son patron pour aller plus
loin et finalement un caméraman lui
arracher ce sont des mains parce que je
pense que l'humain a pris a pris le
dessus sur la production n'a pas fait
défaut paris les leaders du bâtiment ce
que ce que vous racontez c'est du
harcèlement moral qui est un délit et
d'après mes informations vous songé à
aller en justice à porter plainte ou
tout voilà et il ya une autre forme de
menaces qu'ils aient l'obligation au
sein de la production notamment par
certaines productrice de vous mettre en
couple et si vous ne vous mettez pas en
couple vous êtes viré et là c'est
presque alors justement voudrait
s'arrêter le oui est ce qu'on vous dit
dans les castings avant ou pendant
l'aventuré il faut absolument vous
mettre en couple les précommandes que si
vous mettez pas en couple vous sortez
c'est plus pendant l'aventuré
sur des termes du genre si t'es pas prêt
à le faire il ya 2006 avait sur la table
en gros tu as déjà un peu de pression en
nous disant qu'on risque de nous faire
sortir juste parce qu'on a pas envie de
faire ça on n'est pas d'accord génétique
on vous dit ouais on vous dit quoi dans
le cercueil géraldine c'est du passé
même temps modernes en fait à la télé à
avoir des relations sexuelles
on vous dit radiant vous dire où vous
aviez vous à dire des choses comme ça
vous a dit alors moi je sais qu'au bout
de mon deuxième programme j'ai subi
beaucoup de pression parce que je ne
voulais pas me mettre en couple avec un
garçon parce que moi je suis quelqu'un
je suis très entière donc voilà je le
fais si la personne est simple
maintenant c'est vrai qu'on m'a parlé
matin midi et soir
juste pour que je me mette en couple
avec cette personne est en fait comme je
n'allais pas dans le sens de la
production mais en fait on me faisait
comprendre que c'était moi qui faisait
les choses mal donc à un moment d'autres
enfin un moment donné j'ai douté de
moi-même quoi donc j'avais plus
confiance en moi j'étais en train de me
dire mais attendez c'est ma tête qu'on
va voir à la télé demain c'est pas leur
tête à eux donc je peux pas vous avez
exactement
voilà c'est je peux pas me forcément à
faire quelque chose que je n'ai pas
envie de faire donc ces variants genou
pouces c'est à dire que moi par exemple
on m'a on m'a demandé de me mettre en
couple un qu'avec un candidat je l' ai
dit à plusieurs reprises par plusieurs
reprises très clairement que je ne
voulais pas mais n'ont pas n'ont pas
lâché la faire et je revois ils vous
disent aimer mais pourquoi et pourtant
voilà dans son casting avant tu disait
pourtant tu trouvais beau dit non mais
je veux être que je trouvais mot
physiquement maintenant je le vendrais
je ne veux pas j'ai une matière page et
c'était la pression est gentil mais en
fait si mauvais en vous avez mené ici
comme un morceau de viande uniquement
pour pour nourrir ce candidat s'est
pincé fallait pas plus à la peine il ya
d'autres choses folles carew d'aller
voir parce que c'est incroyable
un acte anr vous qui est une des
premières voix la candidate vous
confirmer tout ça vaut aussi on a voulu
vous mettiez en couple voilà qu'on a
l'impression de vide quand on voit ce
genre d'émission on a l'impression
disent pas possible ils ont tous des
coups de foudre tous l'amour et en fait
non non c'est un peu à ça rit ça peut
arriver mais pas arrivé il y en a qui se
peut bien sûr qui au fur et à mesure
baisse comment pouvons nous raconter
votre casting
bayrou c'est complètement fou pas mon
cas c'est complètement fou en face c'est
un premier casting c'est pas le location
bouge et où j'ai fait les anges csv
d'avant d'accord où j'ai 18 ans d'accord
mais je suis employé est en fait je suis
dans mon casting où ce train d'expliquer
en fait aux producteurs que je suis
donc vraiment c'est le contexte et
quelle est ta viande selon moi je dis
bah voila je suis employé me prête à
envoyer
bah voila j'ai pas mes parents inquiets
tu veux faire quoi
j'aimerais bien revenir blogueuse ah et
sinon tu te rentre souvent des trucs
il a regardé excuse moi j'ai pas compris
la question c'est à dire tu trouve
souvent des trucs en grève on essaiera
si je me rends très des godes dans mon
vagin
donc je voyais pas trop où était la
place à la question suite à ça j'ai été
très perturbé donc j'ai préféré quitter
le tournage de mon rap et en disant
qu'ils avaient adoré ma réaction
évidemment puisque j'ai insulté le
producteur mondial a du caractère quoi
ces minutes c'est quoi ce tribunal pour
vous pousser à bout pour voir si vous
avez des carrières ont goûté ces sales
histoires en fait c'était et non mais ce
à quoi vous êtes en question quoi
d'autre comme comme question bat même la
produit une productrice donc lors de mon
tournage des anges quand elle a vu que
je voulais pas me mettre en couple elle
est venue me voir en me disant mais dis
moi toi en fait elle fait un casting de
[ __ ] et là tu fais la prude mais
normal gens comme si c'était une lettre
à la poste tout à fait normal et gt mais
georges choqué de ce qu'on veut de lui
majeure
quand je suis allé voir une la
productrice encore pour lui dire le jour
de mon jour off on est un jour off
je ne suis pas censé travailler on est
censé être tranquille à l'heure actuelle
on m'envoie un candidat qui passe sa
journée à me demander combien je prends
pour une fellation que je suis une
escorte à cause d'une paire de
chaussures que j'avais osé porter voilà
apparemment trop jeune pour porter une
paire de chaussures de marque ça voulait
dire que j'avais forcément [ __ ] et du
coucher aller vers la productrice j'ai
fait écouter ça fait depuis rodez
dimanche 16h il ya toute la production
et à tous les journalistes
il ya tout le monde sur mon lieu de
travail on ne transfère les photos de la
promo d'un candidat qui est en train de
vous dire devant tout le monde que je
suis une escorte qui me demandent de
sucer la [ __ ] me dit c'est ça touche
qu'on te dicter une [ __ ] secte en une
ola laissons répond à ça qu'est-ce qu'on
répond à ça ils enverraient swico savoir
que la production trembler à l'idée que
vous témoignez woods est très courageuse
parce que vous avez eu des pressions
extrêmement fortes et jeudi avant que
présomption d'innocence du côté de la
production réactions ici ces témoignages
sont confirmées en justice
on n'est ni plus ni moins tant de
l'incitation à la prostitution
mais si la production il s'avère que la
production organisé légitime et ça bien
sûr on va aller là pour l'instant les
propos n'engagent que l'on gère
41 mais c'est vrai que voilà la
production faisant qu'on aura la vie de
la production de la production dans
l'est dans les prochains jours guillaume
genton moyenne question si vous laisser
toutes les coulisses de ces émissions
existent aussi le déplorable que vous le
décrivez pourquoi vous y retourner là où
vous en effet plusieurs des téléréalités
parti veut répondre nous a promis que
abbès allait être autrement que ça
n'allait pas recommencer qu'on n'allait
pas être confronté avec les gens avec
qui on avait déjà eu des altercations
mais au final ça recommence à chaque
fois donc à un moment donné nous conduit
ses stops quoi mes derniers mois j'ai
fait la première émission des anges dans
la première saison
enfin on est quand même à des années
lumière de ce que j'assure que ça a bien
changé
avec dix ans déjà non mais je désire la
première édition déjà n'y avait pas de
scénarii vous vous dites que tout est
écrit et je vous devez ces buttes écrit
alors qu'est ce que voulait dire c'est à
dire vous on vous a dit tu vas jouer tel
rôle aussi non en fait on sait que j'ai
le rôle alors moi je suis quelqu'un je
me bats beaucoup pour la justice en télé
voilà y'a que leurs candidats qui sont
beaucoup favorisé par la prod
moi je suis contre ces gens là
maintenant je suis plus du genre à
défendre mes amis quand ils n'ont pas
tort le savent que je suis quelqu'un qui
ne se laisse pas faire qui a du
caractère
donc je pense que ce rôle là ils le
savent ils le connaissent et à chaque
langue revenir pour ça maintenant c'est
vrai qu'on a connu noté me connaît pour
ça aussi et on me sollicite parce que
aussi le public nous aime donc c'est
pour ça qu'ils nous rappellent à chaque
fois parce qu'ils savent que si on est
dans le programme une l'audience donc
juste angèle rania et et natanya juste
j'ai entendu dire
dites moi si c'est vrai ou si c'est faux
quand vous demander aussi si vous
vouliez devenir escort ce que c'est
vraiment apprendre à pour ma part ça ne
m'est jamais arrivé pas pour ma part
mais j'en ai entendu parler mais c'est
pas pour la vè quoi sur d'autres
candidates on leur dit quoi on vend ce
point c'est qu'apparemment il ya des
gens de la production qui sont en
contact avec d'autres gens qui après
faut faire de la procession a défié et
les mettre en contact et voilà fini les
gens de les arrêter ils étaient même un
code appelé les liquides ou sur saône et
d'installer les codes dubaï on prend pas
oui je dis non je disais que c'est une
vieille légende ne savons pas mais cette
menace se profile deux candidates on les
appelle profil dubaï
c'est à dire dans les jambes des défis
dont on soupçonne ou d'autres ont dit
qu'elles sont en mesure d'aller
travailler à dubaï dans le cas de la
prostitution qui serait due à l'essor et
à l'époque de
de ces crêtes story quand on fait des
castings qui avait une suspicion de ça
on se renseigne et on écarte aider les
candidats à mener jusqu'au bout à l'est
d'hilla c'est vrai que c'est une chose
qu'on a déjà entendu c'est assez grave
mais c'est voilà je n'ai entendu aussi
alors en gêne c'est vous qui avez mis le
feu aux poudres en fait qui avait
dénoncé tout c'est toutes ces pratiques
est ce qu est la violence est ce qu il
ya de la dent les voilà dans danser
téléralité on dit qu'il ya déjà des
candidats agressif
voilà des leaders qui équivaut à arsène
we gonna qu'est ce que c'est ça se
matérialise par quoi alors chaque
candidate avec une histoire différente
d'accord oui j'avais clairement jean
recueilli les propos d'autres candidates
qui ont clairement été on leur a tiré
les cheveux on les a étranglé on les a
frappés moi pour ma part à moi comme je
les dis on m'a aspergé le visage tant de
produits ménagers mon cas et puis un
candidat un soit donc un candidat qui
est spécialisée et je le dis bien
spécialisés dans leur scellement donc
envers les femmes c'est son petit truc
il le fait à chaque à chaque année s'est
approché de moi en me disant clairement
coûtant les caméras en disant j'en ai
rien à [ __ ] de la production tu vas
voir
en s'avançant vers moi et tout le monde
s'est retrouvé là il a bien compris
évidemment qu'avaient les caméras et il
a dit c'est ma cema c'est ma femme qui
va te casser la gueule
de quoi là et gt gt à bout et c'est moi
on a qu on a isolé c'est à dire que
c'est pas lui c'est pas l'agresseur
c'est moi c'est moi la victime qu'on a
qu'on a mis de côté c'est à dire que la
production entourée en me disant ans
jacques calme-toi alors que je n'avais
rien fait et que pendant ce temps le
candidat était de l'autre côté du jardin
en train de créer je vais tuer ta mère
et ton père suite à ça on va monter à
l'étagé on pouvait déjà plus j'étais à
bout c'était cette non stop vous m'avez
vu hélas encore une fois deux autres
candidats arrivent et une candidate qui
est elle aussi spécialisée dans le
harcèlement me dis toi tu vas voir tu as
la chance qu'elle vivait à côté de toi
mais tôt ou tard tu l'a alors cette
gifle tu vas tu la manges et tu vas te
l'apprendre
donc c'est ça c'est expliqué najah
littéraire qu'il ya une ambiance voilà
deux ans une ambiance de violence de
violence mais je suis moi ya pas d n'a
pas de la sécurité il n'y a pas de la
production si la sécurité mais la
sécurité on a fait pas intervenir mois
plusieurs fois et des séquences où les
candidats par
exemple rania a failli se prendre un
coup de poing à un millimètre de son
visage par un candidat
et quand le vigile devant intervenir la
connexion il dit ne parvient pas il ne
casse pas la séquence non si c'est un
sens à savoir que je crois qu'il n'y a
vait ça ça n'existe pas de norme avant
ouais parce que je sais d'ailleurs
pourquoi il ya eu la sécurité avant
parce que nous on fait un soir donc avec
une autre candidate qui avec une large
seulement avec moi qui s'appelle céline
lors du tournage des anges aux on a été
en quasiment enterrée vivante en fait
pendant qu'on dormait donc il ya
d'autres candidats qui sont partis en
boîte de nuit
nous on ne faisait pas partie de cette
séquence donc en fait on est juste passé
se coucher on dormait tranquillement et
en fait on s'est fait réveiller par une
sorte de bruit de verre brisé et quand
on s'est tourné l'une vers l'autre on
s'est vus couvert de terre et des gros
pots de pamiers en fait qui était sur
nous pendant qu'on dormait de là on
appelle le producteur ce que le
producteur était défoncée il ya de la
drogue non oui pendant y'en a réalisé la
drogue et moyaux il ya de la drogue
d'alcool
il ya là la drogue il ya là de regagner
la production le sait bien elle est
fournie par la production allait fourni
par la police
moi je sais pas ce que c'est très grave
on dirait que oui mais c'est vrai que
vous dites qu'il ya de la drogue qui est
fourni par la production pourquoi c'est
pour que les cc c'est incroyable ce que
vous dites parce que c'est quoi comme
drogue la cocaïne ken cocaïne oui elle
est contre les tournages se passe en
général on est payé à l'étranger donc
vous doutez bien que les candidats vont
pas prendre le risque de passer les
frontières avec de la drogue
cette drogue là là là si si j'ai une
question que la non mais je suis son
combat qui ça ça c'est un scandale
bah oui c'est un scandale c'est sané
cloud qui parlait mais le parc par
contre j'ai besoin de comprendre
pourquoi vos personne n'a voulu quitter
brutalement la production et vous fait
asperger la tête s'il ya de la drogue si
les quitter en mars refusé mais comment
on peut vous refuser même raisonnement
est attribué au 3 rue
vous n'avez plus en plus à des histoires
peut-être qu'il aimait y pas si oui
chose mais sa sécu sera pas payé ça oui
c'est tournage nous sommes isolés ou
sommes nous à notre famille est loin de
nos proches et ils nous font un
véritable travail psychologique
j'ai voulu quitter le tournage mais
quand je vous dis que j'ai insisté
pendant une heure j'ai dit c'est bon je
ne veux plus je veux partir je veux
rentrer chez moi
le nom angèle on a trop besoin de toi tu
es génial tu es super alors que j'étais
en train de subir un acharnement et est
donc c'est tout un travail psychologique
mais il faut savoir aussi qu il ne passe
pas au téléphone portable alors juste
angel rania et nathaniel j'aimerais
qu'on vienne 2 petites secondes sur ce
que vous venez de dire parce que c'est
extrêmement grave si elle ne dit qu'il
ya de la drogue de la cocaïne sur les
tournages de cette télé réalité qu'elle
est fournie par la production comment ça
se passe racontez nous parce qu'on a
envie de savoir mais sûrement à se
passer quoi y'a un mec de la production
non prend pas donc on va vraiment vous
dire qu'il dit là mais un bon mais tu
sais quoi c'est des candidates qui
demande à la production c'est un secret
de polichinelle mais oui ce sont les
candidats qui est qui je ne savais pas
qu allez vous l'avez vu la production et
il en moi un moment vous mais d'autres
candidates va bien arriver
oui oui bien sûr ça n'est jamais arrivé
et enfin je parle bien et la production
elle elle dit quoi elle se dit pas que
ça va leur tomber dessus au moment que
vend maintenant et non non ils agissent
en tout entre puissance et ça qui est
incroyable c'est que non c'est bon les
témoignages sont incroyables d'une
violence inouïe parce que en plus cette
drogue que vous affirmez donc fournie
par la production elle servirait à des
candidats pour être désinhibé faire
qu'ils prennent de la drogue ils sont de
plus en plus violente plus en plus
menaçant c'est ça oui en fait ils ont
des réactions mais complètement
inattendu brillant oui ou pour un non
genre vraiment on peut se prendre enfin
moi j'ai fait me prendre une bougie pour
une sorte de g pas faire un câlin à la
bonne personne le matin j'ai pas fait un
câlin là à une fille en première je me
suis retrouvé mon lit par terre une
villa à dos et d'une bougie caf à nîmes
volley au visage est-ce que vous avez
une parfois peur pour votre vie pour
votre intégrité physique est ce que vous
avez eu des moments où vraiment vous
avez eu très peur rania peur elle a dit
un instant que vous aviez failli prendre
un coup - figure
oui la personne n'a pas été sanctionné
donc d'un garçon oui et toujours dans le
dans la banque que tu fais toujours les
personnes a continué l'aventuré
maintenant c est juste envie réglé
aujourd'hui mais mais c'est vrai que oui
on peut avoir peur maintenant on sait
que là il ya quand même du monde avec
nous donc forcément fait attendre sur
les salles mais qui skie que je dois
dire c'est que en fait on n'a plus
confiance en nous quand on sort de ce
programme là parce que en fait on est on
a un psychologue avant de faire le
tournage et en sortant de ce tournage
une fois qu'on a plus confiance en nous
on est enfermés chez nous qu'on ait
crois que c'est chez nous quand même
pendant plusieurs jours parce que on a
le contrecoup de l'émission parce que
vaut avoir l'habitude quand même d'être
entouré de caméras d'être avec 15
personnes le matin le midi le soir quand
arrive chez toi tu es tout seul enfin
moi je vous le dis sincèrement j'ai déjà
fait une dépression et ça c'est sans
vous mentir parce que j'en suis à mon
quatrième programme et un moment donné
je me remets en question en me disant
mais peut-être que c'est ma faute
peut-être que j'ai mal fait les choses
enfin voilà alors je vais vous dire ce
que ce que dit la la production parce
qu'on les a contactés il demandera
d'ailleurs la réponse d'un des candidats
des anges qui qui viendra répondre sur
ce plateau
ils nous ont dit c'est leur version bien
entendu que vous étiez que vous étiez
bourg et que vous étiez sous lorsqu'il
ya eu ces altercations et que c'était
vous qui étiez coupable c'est pour ça
que vous enfermez voilà c'est que vous
vous étiez en état d'ébriété du coup
toutes les autres saisons les autres
victimes n'a ce n'est pas non mais il y
en a d'autres gens je vous laisse
savourer on est tout bourré on est
toutes des alcooliers connaît tout des
folles mais vous saviez que vous
connaissiez leur version blanche
exactement oui on a exactement cette
raison que nous allons porter plainte
voilà nous sommes représentés par m
cohen est maître assous d'ailleurs qui
connaît très bien la grosse équipe
puisqu'il a gagné tous ses procès contre
7 chez les autres et bien voilà c'est
donc en fait c'est ses limites semaine
dernière à la partie
1er supporter lui ai donc oui c'est donc
à ces méthodes qu'ils utilisent pour
nous impressionner pourront faire taire
ça ne marche plus mais bon c'est terminé
on n'est plus tout seul maintenant on
est ensemble on est soudé et on va aller
jusqu'au bout on va mener le combat il
va le gagner mais vous savez que ce que
vous venez de dire c'est une bombe
c'est une bombe ouvrière de nom mais
jamais vite que diatta drogue qui
concerne télé réalité mais vu et à
l'alcool bon voilà l'alcool c'est grave
la drogue mans de l'intimidation la
production abel la ccin drame sportif et
espérer qu est ce que ça risque gilles
c'est quoi ça ah la la production peut
être vraiment inquiété parce que s'ils
fournissent ces du deal
donc il pourrait être inculpé déjà
harcèlement moral c'est vous pouvez
faire deux ans de prison c'est du deal
là si c'est avéré ça va être très grave
moi je vais vous dire franchement si
c'est avéré si ça va en justice
c'est de toute façon la fin non
seulement des anges le périnée de cette
production en tant que tel parce que si
vos témoignages sont vraies alors on
aura la réponse à la région nommée ya
présomption d'innocence voilà quatre à
l'isolément
merci les témoignages sont avérés c'est
la fin des anges qui se disputera sans
mêlée si je suis repassé sur moi j'ai
une question assez terre à terre mais
est-ce que vous avez des preuves pour
appuyer vos témoignages au succès que
parole contre parole
non non vous avez des messages vous avez
des troubles il ya des preuves en année
vous avez quoi comme avant mais il du
coup on a des mails des échanges avec la
production disent quoi parce que vous
partez au niveau de la burqa c'est ça
c'est pas on peut pas le prouver
le meneur au niveau de la preuve c'est
vrai qu'on peut pas le prouver après la
chance d'avoir deux ans que ce
témoignage même devant la rue duke
d'enseignement de leur abolition de
production et je pense que la ccq
l'effet boule de neige donc en fait
c'est un projet alors qu'est ce que vous
répondez aux gens qui nous unit ou un
mini c'est parce que peut-être que la
prod ne voulait plus d'elle
donc elle crache dans la soupe qu'est ce
que vous répondez je suis
la fin du programme d'ailleurs je vais
bientôt repasser à la télé est
d'ailleurs en gel devait revenir avec
moi pour la fin du programme c'est elle
qui a choisi de revenir
donc je pense que là déjà c'est pas
cohérent ce qu'ils disent
maintenant c'est un problème qui dure
depuis des années il ya des gens qui ont
parlé en étant tout seul sauf que ça n'a
pas fait autant de bruit qu'à l'heure
actuelle il a suffit juste d'un gel pour
que tout le monde ça ramène sa version
de l'histoire
en fait vous devez être soigné
maintenant parce que c'est angèle cas
qui a dit qu'à commencer à à dire voilà
ce qui se passait sur cette production
est derrière les autres ont suivi
pourquoi on est tellement énorme et
recel et déjà les filles elles ont parlé
mais elle doit en parler avait un peu
plus tard parce que comme je les dis à
tout un travail psychologique et puis on
a peur aussi quand même parce que on a
été détruite ce économiquement
quand vous avez quinze personnes qui
vous humilie constamment vous remettez
en question
donc vous vous dites peut-être que c'est
une problème parce que c'est ce que la
production nous dire mais mais mais tout
vous dire j'ai prévenu les patrons la
production et dans leur disant ça va
peut-être
j'ai vécu des trucs incroyables pas que
seulement que le producteur d'émissions
mêlée le le projet le président le
directeur général de la production un
truc comme ça alors du comment on nous
traite clairement n'a plus confiance et
nous avons 400 me globo on vous traite
bien et clairement comme de la merde
jour ils disent quoi que vous dites on
bat est ce que ces labos avoir 30 ans 29
ans quand tu arrives dans un programme
comme ça tu es comme un gosse dans un
pensionnat donc on ne se dit pas faire
c'est comme si c'est comme ça c'est là
bas donc il savait que vous alliez
parler en bon eh oui
conquise et que c'est à moi que vous
avez reçue dessous d'eux il ya deux ans
que ça que j'ai fait une interview avec
samira bref j allais de la drogue j'ai
parlé de la prostitution j'ai parlé j'ai
pas être déjà de tout ça est à l'heure
actuelle il avait déjà posté je prêt
énergie 2 avait posté un communiqué
alors les narines et la chaîne n'a rien
à voir là une commande un programme
répondu avec celle communiquée qu'on
croit il respecter les causes de la
femme lara l'énergie simon cc
c'est la chaîne mais même si on répond
le vous sur le live j'ai mis en cause
son sujet mais nrj 12 les pauvres ou dj
oui mais là je prend leur défense c'est
que il donne la responsabilité une
production à la presse et à la
production bien entendu pas deux ans il
n'y ait pas de 2,2 voilà deux de plus de
drogues d'alcool de l comme un oui et
surtout il n'était même pas sur le
tournage cette saison il est pas la
chaîne avec toi vite que les producteurs
y est mais bon oui mais on s'en fout on
leur parle de temps mais vérifier ce que
c'est juste une plaie angèle rania et
natanya joue sans vous êtes de
magnifiques toutes les trois maires
c'est très sympathique vous exprimer
très bien vraiment et moi ce qui me fait
de la peine ce soir en voyant alors je
vous le dis on aura demain voilà la
version de la production s'est tu vois
trois jeunes filles voilà qui qui sont
qui n'ont pas l'air qui m'ont l'air un
châssis qui m'ont l'air intelligent tu
calmes et qui m'ont l'air brisé ouais
alors que vous avez à peine 30 ans
toutes les trois et je sais pas vous
mais moi ça me fait de la peine de voir
trois jeunes filles comme ça est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous regrettez c'est ce
chemin vous avez pris ce qu'il ya plein
de jeunes qui nous regardent et qui ont
envie d'être comme vous vous êtes des
fidèles de plein de jeunes un jeu série
qui vous regardent qui vous adore est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous regrettez et est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous vous dites je me
remettrai jamais de ce que j'ai vécu et
nathaniel par mois là je te sors très
ému ouais rien puisque ça fait deux ans
que j'ai participé à cette émission et
que ça a été les répercussions de mon
interview ont été très graves moi c'est
à dire je me suis pas mal de menaces pas
de certains candidats et se sont tous
mis d'accord sur une version pour dire
que j'étais tu as ma vie personnelle
donc on va carrément chercher dans ta
vie personnelle dans ce que tu as vécu
dans son enfance pour que ce verbe pour
dire que m'a regardé à l'instable a
besoin d'un psychologue et en fait ça
fait deux ans et les filles qui peuvent
en témoigner puisque je ne les
connaissais pas avant cette histoire
faut le savoir je ne les connaissais pas
on s'est rencontré et on s'est soudé par
rapport à ça mais je ne connaissais pas
avant et à peuvent en témoigner que on
m'a mis l'étiquette vous regrettez
dehors fait de la télé réalité mais à la
télé réalité en général je regrette
d'avoir participé à cette émission
vora niort moi je crache pas dans la
soupe parce que grâce à ça quand même je
peux dire la vérité j'ai eu confiance en
moi j'ai eu quand même
carrière dans le métier maintenant c'est
vrai que une émission avec l'illégalité
clairement je ne referai pas et vous
alors regretté le problème c'est que
comme je les dis enfin la télé réalité
il n'ya aucun souci peut avoir des
clashs et c'est là on parle de cette
production en particulier
ouais donc nous on n'a pas à regretter
d'avoir subi tout ça c'est à eux de le
regretter c'est à eux de se sentir
coupable s'il s'adonne depuis qu'on a
lancé tout ça ils ne se sont pas on à
l'exception s'excuser une seule croiront
pas une seule fois sa bulle nono de
souffrance on voulait juste à la passe
d'être justin webb a désolé en fait
juste désolé c'est quoi vos rêves
aujourd'hui on a envie de faire quoi
angèle pas envie de faire quoi mes rêves
mon rêve pour l'instant là c'est qu'on
me rende justice
vraiment c'est certainement pour toi
parce que tu as subi bien ça en fait
simon briser psychologiquement moi je
vais rester
je suis sorti du tournage je suis resté
une semaine sur mon sur mon canapé jour
et nuit je compte me briser j'ai failli
passer mes problèmes procès qu'on s'est
relevé ouais aujourd'hui vous voulez
aller au bout de son nez moitié et on va
y arriver si les détergents et en vain
qu'est ce que vous aimeriez vous
aimeriez quoique l'émission s'arrête que
cette production à l'industrie soit net
est ce qu'on voudrait surtout c'est que
il n'y est plus
ces comportements à la télévision ce
harcèlement
ces humiliations qu'il ya dans cette
émission se acharnement sur un seul
candidat que ce que ces comportements
passés à 18h à l'heure où il ya tous les
gamins qui rendent des courses un peu
plus hier raphaël pépin qui sera avec
nous demain
ok le parti des candidats qui nous
donnera sa version si vous avez quelque
chose à lui dire
ce message moyen de changer avec lui
mais c'est vrai que bon avec un gène ça
serait très mal passé mais la production
que ce que vous avez envie de leur dire
mais bon courage à eux parce que si je
pense qu'on a beaucoup de preuves et
beaucoup de témoignages qui vont sur
nrj12 peuvent pas continuer l'émission
dans ce cas là non non non non non non
non là c'est loin possible en france je
pense et c'est une bombe
vous avez l'air crédible c'est la
réponse est impossible
la présente cinq innovations mais ont
lieu plus regardé l'émission après tout
ça mais c'est aussi une chose que la
grosse équipe a perdu tous ses procès
ouais tout cela sans exception